Ang variational quantum eigensolver o VQE ay isa sa mga pinakaunang hybrid quantum classical algorithm at ito ay
interesante sa ilang dahilan Una tulad ng makikita natin sa video na ito ito ay isang promising na diskarte para sa ilang uri ng problema Pangalawa ito ay mahalaga
sa kasaysayan at nagbukas ng daan para sa maraming pinahusay na algorithm tulad ng adapt VQE
At sa wakas ang VQE ay medyo simple madaling maunawaan kung ano ang ginagawa ng quantum at classical computers sa algorithm na ito
at kung paano sila nakikipag-ugnayan Mayroong apat na pangunahing bahagi ng isang VQE na kalkulasyon
Una may isang operator madalas na isang Hamiltonian na tatawagin nating H na naglalarawan ng isang katangian ng sistema na
gusto mong i-optimize Ang isa pang paraan ng pagsasabi nito ay naghahanap ka ng eigenvector ng operator na ito na
katumbas ng minimum na eigenvalue Madalas nating tinatawag ang eigenvector na iyon na ground state
Susunod may isang ansatz na salitang nangangahulugang diskarte Ito ay isang quantum circuit na naghahanda ng isang quantum state na humahawak sa
eigenvector na hinahanap mo Sa katunayan ang ansatz ay isang pamilya ng mga quantum circuit dahil ang ilan sa mga gate sa
ansatz ay parameterized Ibig sabihin binibigyan sila ng isang parameter na maaari nating baguhin Ang pamilya ng mga quantum circuit na ito
ay maaaring maghanda ng isang pamilya ng mga quantum state na humahawak sa ground state
Susunod kailangan natin ng estimator isang paraan ng pag-estimate ng expectation value ng operator H sa kasalukuyang variational
quantum state Kung minsan ang talagang iniingatan natin ay simpleng ang expectation value na ito na
tinatawag nating cost function Kung minsan naman ang iniingatan natin ay isang mas kumplikadong function na maaari pa ring isulat mula sa
isa o higit pang mga expectation value
Sa wakas kailangan natin ng isang classical optimizer isang algorithm na nagbabago ng mga parameter upang subukang i-minimize ang cost function na ito
I-outline natin ang problemang gusto nating solusyunan at ang pangkalahatang diskarte bago tugunan kung paano gumaganap ang quantum ng isang papel
Maaari nating i-cast ang maraming optimization problem na kritikal sa agham at industriya bilang mga matrix value problem Karaniwang gusto mo
ng minimum na eigenvalue ng iyong matrix at ang eigenvector na katumbas nito Ang matrix H ay maaaring
isang Hamiltonian na naglalarawan ng enerhiya ng isang pisikal na sistema At ang minimum na eigenvalue ay magiging ang ground state energy
E0 at ang eigenvector ay magiging ang katumbas na quantum ground state na madalas na tinutukoy bilang psi sub zero
O ang matrix ay maaaring maglalarawan ng isang kumplikadong cost function na kaugnay ng mga combinatorial optimization problem
tulad ng sa logistics at ang eigenstate s subopt ay magiging isang optimal na solusyon ng
problema tulad ng isang binary string na naglalabel ng isang cut sa isang graph ng isang distribution network Sa praktika ito ay
karaniwang marinig ang termino na Hamiltonian na ginagamit para sa lahat ng matrix ng interes kahit sa labas ng pisikal na agham Sabihin nating
interesado tayo sa isang matrix na may n rows at n columns Ang ganitong mga problema ay maaaring masolusyunan nang mabilis at eksaktong gamit ang
mga classical solver para sa n hanggang ilang daan o libu-libo na walang mga pagpapalagay na ginawa tungkol sa matrix Para sa mga sparse
matrix na may karamihang mga zero bilang mga entry maaari itong maging mas malaki na ang n ay mataas ng isang bilyon kahit sa isang laptop
Ngunit para sa tunay na napakalaking mga problema na lumagpas sa mga bilang na ito ang approximate o heuristic na mga pamamaraan ay madalas na kinakailangan
Habang mas malaki ang matrix at mas hindi sparse mas mahirap ang problema at mas maraming matalinong trick ang dapat gamitin Ipagpalagay na ang iyong matrix ay napakalaki
na ang exact diagonalization ay hindi isang opsyon Ipagpalagay pa na alam mo ang sapat tungkol sa iyong problema upang
makagawa ng ilang hula tungkol sa pangkalahatang istraktura ng target state at gusto mong mag-probe ng mga state na katulad ng iyong
paunang hula upang makita kung ang iyong gastos o enerhiya ay maaaring mas mababa pa Ito ay isang variational na diskarte at isa itong pamamaraan
na ginagamit kapag ang exact diagonalization ay hindi isang opsyon gamit ang isang classical computer Ito ay gagana tulad ng sumusunod
Una gumawa ka ng isang guess state na may ilang parameter na theta na ibibago mo
Kahit na ang paunang hula na ito ay maaaring random hindi ito pinapayuhan Gusto nating gamitin ang kaalaman ng problema sa kamay
upang iayon ang ating hula hangga't maaari
Pangalawa kalkulahin natin ang expectation value ng operator na ang sistema ay nasa state na iyon
Pangatlo baguhin natin ang mga variational parameter at ulitin
Pang-apat gamitin natin ang naipong impormasyon tungkol sa landscape ng mga posibleng state sa iyong variational subspace upang gumawa ng mas mahusay at mas mahusay na
mga hula at lumapit sa target state
Ginagarantiyahan ng variational principle na ang ating variational state ay hindi makakagawa ng eigenvalue na mas mababa kaysa sa
target ground state Kaya habang mas mababa ang expectation value mas mahusay ang ating approximation ng ground state
Pag-usapan natin ang kahirapan ng bawat hakbang sa diskarteng ito
Ang pagtatakda o pag-update ng mga parameter ay computationally madali Ang kahirapan doon ay sa pagpili ng kapaki-pakinabang na pisikal na
motivated na mga paunang parameter Ang paggamit ng naipong impormasyon mula sa mga nakaraang iteration upang i-update ang mga parameter sa ganitong
paraan na lumapit ka sa ground state ay hindi trivial Ngunit mayroon ang mga classical optimization algorithm na
ginagawa ito nang medyo mahusay Ang classical optimization na ito ay mahal lamang dahil maaaring kailanganin nito ng maraming
iteration Sa pinakamasamang kaso ang bilang ng mga iteration ay maaaring mag-scale nang exponentially sa n
Ang pinaka-computationally mahal na single step ay halos tiyak na ang expectation value ng iyong matrix gamit ang isang
ibinigay na state Ang n bait n na matrix ay dapat kumilos sa n element vector na katumbas ng order n squared
na mga multiplication operation sa pinakamasamang kaso Ito ay dapat gawin sa bawat iteration ng mga parameter Para sa sobrang
malalaking matrix ito ay may mataas na computational cost Ngayon isipin mo ang paglipat ng bahaging ito ng
kalkulasyon sa isang quantum computer Sa halip na kalkulahin ang expectation value na ito ini-estimate mo ito sa pamamagitan ng paghahanda ng
state s ng theta sa quantum computer gamit ang iyong variational ansatz at pagkatapos ay gumagawa ng mga sukat
Hatiin natin ito nang kaunti Ang H ay karaniwang hindi madaling sukathin Halimbawa maaari itong binubuo ng maraming
hindi commuting na Pauli x y at z operators
Ngunit ang H ay maaaring isulat bilang isang linear combination ng mga term na H sub alpha na bawat isa ay madaling masukat Halimbawa
ang mga Pauli operator o mga grupo ng bitwise commuting na Pauli operators Ang
expectation value ng H sa state S ay ang weighted sum ng mga expectation value ng mga constituent term na H alpha
Ang expression na ito ay nangangapit para sa anumang state s ngunit partikular na gagamitin natin ito kasama ang ating variational state s ng theta
Ang bawat isa sa mga term na h alpha ay maaaring sukathin ng m beses na nagbubunga ng mga measurement sample na s sub alpha j na ang j ay tumatakbo mula sa
1 hanggang m at nagbabalik ng expectation value at isang standard deviation Maaari nating i-sum
ang mga term na ito at ipalaganap ang mga error sa pamamagitan ng sum
Hindi ito nangangailangan ng malaking multiplication ni anumang proseso na kinakailangang nag-scale tulad ng n squared Sa halip
nangangailangan ito ng maraming sukat sa quantum computer Kung hindi mo kailangan ng masyadong marami sa mga iyon ang diskarteng ito ay maaaring
mabisa At iyon ang quantum bahagi ng VQE Ngunit pag-usapan natin ang mga dahilan kung bakit maaaring hindi ito mabisa Isang dahilan
para sa maraming sukat ay upang bawasan ang statistical uncertainty sa iyong mga estimate para sa sobrang mataas na precision
na mga kalkulasyon Isa pang dahilan ay ang bilang ng mga Pauli string na kinakailangan upang saklawin ang iyong buong matrix Dahil ang mga Pauli matrix kasama ang
identity ay sumasaklaw sa espasyo ng lahat ng operator ng isang ibinigay na dimensyon garantisado tayo
na maisusulat natin ang ating matrix ng interes bilang isang weighted sum ng mga Pauli operator gaya ng ginawa natin kanina Dito ang C alpha ay isang
numerical coefficient at ang H alpha ay isang string ng mga Pauli operator na kumikilos sa lahat ng qubit na naglalarawan ng iyong sistema
Ang H alpha ay magkakaroon ng ganitong anyo kung saan ang nth Pauli operator mula sa kanan ay kumikilos sa nth qubit Kaya maaari nating
sukathin ang ating operator sa pamamagitan ng pagsukat ng isang serye ng mga Pauli operator Ngunit hindi natin maaaring sukathin ang lahat ng Pauli operator na iyon
nang sabay-sabay Ang mga Pauli operator na hindi kasama ang identity ay hindi nagko-commute sa isa't isa kung sila ay
kaugnay ng parehong qubit Halimbawa maaari nating sukathin ang I Z IIZ at ZZ
XZ nang sabay-sabay dahil maaari nating sukathin ang I at Z nang sabay-sabay para sa ikatlong
qubit At maaari tayong magkilala ng I at X nang sabay-sabay para sa unang qubit Ngunit hindi tayo maaaring
sumathin ang lahat ng Z at Z ZZ ZX nang sabay-sabay dahil ang Z at X ay hindi
nagko-commute at parehong kumikilos sa zeroth qubit
Kaya dine-decompose natin ang ating matrix H sa isang sum ng mga Pauli na kumikilos sa iba't ibang qubit
Ang ilang elemento ng sum na iyon ay maaaring sukathin nang lahat sa isang pagkakataon Tinatawag natin itong isang grupo ng commuting na Pauli Depende sa
kung gaano karaming hindi commuting na term ang mayroon maaaring kailangan natin ng maraming ganitong grupo Tawagin natin ang bilang ng ganitong grupo ng commuting
na Pauli na t
Kung maliit ang ngcp maaari itong gumana nang maayos
Kung ang h ay may milyun-milyong grupo hindi ito magiging kapaki-pakinabang Itala mo ang expectation value o ang cost function
para sa set ng mga parameter na theta na ginamit sa iyong state at pagkatapos i-update mo ang mga parameter sa paglipas ng panahon Maaari mong gamitin ang
mga expectation value o cost function value na iyong na-estimate upang mag-approximate ng gradient ng iyong cost function sa
subspace ng mga state na sinampol ng iyong ansatz
Parehong gradient-based at gradient-free na classical optimizer ay mayroon parehong dumaranas ng mga potensyal na trainability issue tulad ng
maraming local minima at malalaking rehiyon ng parameter space na may halos zero gradient na tinatawag na barren plateaus
Kaya masosolusyunan ba ng VQE ang lahat ng iyong pinakamahirap na problema Hindi Ngunit ang maging mas mahusay sa lahat ng kalkulasyon ay hindi kailanman ang punto
Inilipat na natin kung ano ang nagtatakda ng computational cost Tingnan kung ano ang ating ipinagpalit Inilipat na natin mula sa isang proseso
na ang complexity ay nakasalalay lamang sa matrix dimension patungo sa isa na nakasalalay sa kinakailangang precision at bilang ng
hindi commuting na Pauli operator na bumubuo sa matrix Ang huling bahagi ay walang katumbas sa classical computing
Batay sa mga bagong dependency na ito para sa mga sparse matrix o mga matrix na may kakaunting hindi commuting na Pauli string ang
proseso ay maaaring maging kapaki-pakinabang Ito ang kaso para sa mga sistema ng mga nakikipag-ugnayan na spin Halimbawa para sa mga dense matrix maaari itong
maging mas hindi kapaki-pakinabang Alam natin halimbawa na ang mga chemical system ay madalas na may mga Hamiltonian na kinabibilangan ng daan-daan libo-libo kahit
milyun-milyong Pauli string Mayroong mga interesanteng gawain na nagawa upang mabawasan ang bilang ng mga term na ito ngunit
ang mga chemical system ay maaaring mas angkop sa ilan sa mga iba pang algorithm na tatalakayin natin sa kursong ito
Ang epektibong paggamit ng VQE ay nangangailangan din na alam natin ang mga katangian ng ating target state at maaaring pumili ng isang mabuting pisikal na
motivated na paunang state pati na rin ng isang mabuting ansatz na may medyo kakaunting variational parameter Maaari itong maging
lubhang mahirap Ipinakikita ng VQE kung paano ang mga lakas ng classical at quantum computer ay maaaring pagsamahin
nang hindi nagdadagdag ng mas kamakailang mga pamamaraan Hindi tinutulungan tayo ng VQE na masolusyunan ang mga problema na hindi masolusyunan ng mga classical computer ngunit
nagpapatuloy itong gumanap ng isang papel sa pagbuo ng algorithm At tinuturuan din tayo ng VQE na ang paglipat ng isang hakbang mula sa classical
patungo sa mga quantum computer ay hindi mas mahusay o mas masama para sa lahat ng layunin Sa halip
binabago nito kung anong mga salik ang nagtatakda ng kahusayan ng iyong algorithm Ito ay isang mahalagang pangkalahatang aral sa quantum
classical hybrid computing